TIM HOCKIN: When you see
somebody work on Kubernetes
for the first time and they
realize what it's actually
capable of doing, and they
get this spark of like,
wow, that was really amazing.
That was incredible, I
didn't know I could do that.
That moment is what
keeps me going.
KELSEY HIGHTOWER: Kubernetes
is a container management
platform.
It's open source.
If you have a
collection of machines
you can package up your
applications and containers
and give it to Kubernetes
and it'll run it for you.
CHEN GOLDBERG: What it
gives developers is actually
the luxury of not caring
about the infrastructure.
Kubernetes on its own is
taking care of monitoring,
logging, scaling,
and other things that
are required in other
managing applications,
in productions, et cetera.
APARNA SINHA: Kubernetes,
the word stands for helmsman.
Kubernetes is that
system that makes sure
that your applications
are always
afloat and always accessible
in a sea of resources
that is the cloud.
TIM HOCKIN: It was really
critical, in my opinion,
to open source Kubernetes.
KELSEY HIGHTOWER: So
Google started the project
based on what we knew about how
things worked inside of Google.
But having contributors
like Red Hat and others
allowed us to
actually figure out
how to make it work
for the outside world.
And that was the key to
success for Kubernetes.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
CHEN GOLDBERG: We really needed
to think about the adoption.
What the customers will
know, or the users.
So, originally, we really
were focusing on ease of use.
And documentation
and understanding,
like, what is their
familiarity in order
for them to use the technology.
BRIAN GRANT: About
six months of work,
we delivered something of
value to external customers.
KELSEY HIGHTOWER:
GKE is probably
the best production-ready
Kubernetes install you can get.
You click a single button.
In about five minutes,
we'll give you
this production ready cluster
with full lifecycle management.
So what we're trying to do is
take GKE, and package it up
in Anthos, and give
you the ability
to do the same thing on Prem
and even other cloud providers.
LAURENT GABET: We moved
from a stand up processing
to a microservices processing.
And without Kubernetes it
there was no way to do that.
It's an open source so
it was important for us
not to be glued in a provider.
So now we're on Premise.
We are deploying
Kubernetes ourselves.
And on GCP we are using GKE.
APARNA SINHA: Kubernetes
is everywhere.
It's being used by your bank,
your retailer, your pizza shop.
CHUCK RHOADES: Pizza
Hut uses Kubernetes
to run a large portion of
our e-commerce services
and infrastructure.
It's extremely important
for us that our services
be available when our customers
want to purchase food from us.
Kubernetes has
impacted our business
by giving us just a really
great, fast speed to market
on delivering technology.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
BRANDON JUNG: We made the
migration from Azure to GCP.
We did it for a
couple major reasons.
First off the quality of
the engineering on GCP.
The second piece that was
really big was Kubernetes.
We are a development company.
We're all about helping
people write the next thing
they want to build.
And that's going to
be done in Kubernetes.
CHEN GOLDBERG: The
future of Kubernetes,
it's very similar to
what infrastructure are
doing for Google developers.
We want to empower
developers everywhere
to innovate without needing
to care about infrastructure
or problems that we
already solved for them.
And we started seeing some
sparks of those kind of things,
really amazing
innovation of what people
are using Kubernetes for.
And I expect we'll see
more and more amazing ideas
and how software is
really changing the world.
KELSEY HIGHTOWER:
I can't believe
I'm talking to software, but
happy anniversary, Kubernetes.
TIM HOCKIN: Happy birthday
to Kubernetes, the project,
and the community.
And thank you so much to the
thousands of people who make
my life very, very exciting.
APARNA SINHA: Happy fifth
anniversary, Kubernetes.
You continue to
inspire and amaze.